In this video, we're going to go
through the process of Pinning
a data set to Posit
Connect using the pins package.
So over here on
the left hand side,
we have a pins demo
R script, and we're
going to walk through
all of these steps.
The first thing we'll do
is install the pins package
and then load the pins
package into our environment.
So I'll highlight these lines
of code and I'll hit Run.
Now, in order to use pins, you
first have to define a board.
And so for this
workflow, we're going
to use Posit Connect
as our board.
The first thing we need to
do is register our board.
So the easiest way to do that is
to go to tools, global options
and select publishing.
So the top of my
screen I go to tools,
all the way to the bottom,
we have global options.
And towards the bottom,
we have publishing.
Currently, I do not have any
Posit Connect instances
registered, so we're going
to connect to a new one.
So I'll click Connect
here in the top, right?
We're going to choose
Posit Connect,
and here is where you
want to provide the URL
of your Connect instance.
I'll select next and we get this
pop up menu to connect to R
that all looks
good will connect.
I can close out of this
and then connect account.
All right.
So we've now connected to our
instance of Posit Connect.
I can apply these
changes and hit.
OK all right.
So now that we've
registered our Posit Connect
and since we first need to
define this connect instance
as our board, and to do that,
we're going to use the board,
connect, function
from the pins package.
And we will call
this my board, so
let me run this line of code.
And you can see at the bottom
connecting, to Posit Connect
and there's the URL
for my connect instance
and now we can actually
pin the data set.
So in this example, we're going
to use the pin write function
from the pins package and we're
going to pin the mtcars
data set.
We're going to pin it to
my connect instance, which
we registered in
the previous step.
We're going to call it
Mtcars data set.
You can call it
whatever you want.
Now we're going to save
this pin as a CSV file,
so let's highlight all this.
Will hit run, at the
bottom of the screen
You can see writing to pin Ryan.
It's me, mtcars data set.
And now we can actually switch
over to Posit Connect
and I can show you what a
pinned data set looks like.
So here's the pin data set
the mtcars data set.
You can actually get a
snippet of what the data
set looks like right here and
you can actually scroll across.
But most importantly,
with pins, you
want to know how to pull this
pin into your own workflow,
into your own script,
whatever you're developing,
and it provides the
code and how to do that.
So we're going to take
this code and come back
to Posit Workbench,
see RStudio IDE, within
Posit Workbench
here, and we're
going to read in
that pin data set.
So we'll use the pin read
function from the pins package.
We're going to again
let pins know this
is the board I want to use.
And I'm going to
pull in this pin.
That's my name, the
Mtcars dataset.
So let's run that
and then you'll
see here my console here
is the Printed out pins,
pin mtcars,
data set, and that
is how you pin a data
set to Posit Connect.